[Music]
we got news just a few hours ago that
comedy legend Sid Caesar passed away and
I wanted to speak about this very
briefly because when I was a kid growing
up in Brookline Massachusetts my father
one day took me to the hearthstone Plaza
in Brookline village to see something
called ten from your show of shows
you've never heard of that and it was it
was Sid Cesar's greatest sketches from
your show of shows which was his sketch
show in the 1950s all put together the
best of them as a movie and I didn't
know what my dad was talking about
he said you got to see this I don't know
how I would have been 10 years old 11 he
took me lights go down I watched this
and when it was over I thought to myself
I don't know what that guy is doing but
I want to do that yeah it was so
powerful to me he was so funny he was so
great acknowledged by pretty much
everybody who ever worked with him as
the funniest person ever
yeah and influenced an entire generation
and everything that anybody's doing in
comedy today you could probably trace it
all back to Sid Caesar so I just want to
say to two young people who are maybe
watching right now go online look up
some of Sid Caesar sketches because the
best way to remember him is through his
work he was great and they'll never be
anybody
the best of all time
[Applause]